ist einer der aufmüpfigen schriftsteller
unseres landes der schweiz
entwicklungshilfe hat er in seinem roman
hundert tage ein miserables zeugnis
ausgestellt die verschärfung des
asylgesetzes bezeichnet er öffentlich
als schande und in seinem theaterstück
öl demaskiert er unsere abhängigkeit vom
rohstoffmarkt lukas bärfuss heißt der
mann schweizer schriftsteller und
dramatiker der am ersten juni den
solothurner literaturpreis entgegen
nehmen darf
in seinem neuesten roman koala stellt
bärfuss unseren lebensstil in frage der
uns atemlos durchs leben spannend hat
sich meine kollegin barbara bleisch
gedacht und lukas bärfuss eingeladen
lukas bärfuss ihr bruder hat sich das
leben genommen und das ist der
ausgangspunkt ihres neuesten buches klar
warum machen sie ein derart privates
ereignis zum gegenstand eines romans ich
weiß gar nicht ob es so privat ist sonst
suizid selbst baut eine eine sehr
verbreitete angelegenheit ich glaube das
würde ich dass es den privaten den
intimen anlass gibt aber durchaus die
gesellschaftliche relevanz einfach weil
es so verbreitet ist und so häufig in
der schweiz bringen sich jedes jahr über
tausend menschen um
wenn man davon ausgeht dass jeder dieser
menschen 5 nahe angehörige zurücklässt
dann kann man ermessen wie viele
menschen davon betroffen sind und das
ist tatsächlich auch meine erfahrung
jetzt im nachgang des buches das mich
sehr viele menschen ich seit vielen
jahren kenne er ist jetzt darauf
ansprechen dass ich ihn etwas ähnliches
widerfahren ist also der ausgangspunkt
ist möglicherweise sehr privat aber die
zielsetzung durchaus gesellschaftlichen
es gibt eine andere zahl die vielleicht
auch erschreckende sind 40 personen pro
tag in der schweiz die versuchen sich
das leben zu nehmen
wir sind dabei erfolgreich sie sagen an
einer stelle in diesem buch auch
eigentlich sei diese todesart ordinär
fahren lassen sie damit nicht eigentlich
doch menschliche tragödien ordinär her
ist natürlich einfach gewöhnlich und
weit verbreitet und wenn man diese
zahlen höher muss man sagen es ist eine
sehr bewährte traditionsreiche und immer
noch häufig praktizierte kulturtechnik
und wenn man das moralische jetzt einmal
weg lässt muss man sagen die menschen
tun was sie tun ist häufig sie versuchen
jetzt sie versuchen es häufig und
deshalb ist es durchaus eine ordinäre
erscheinung nichts außergewöhnliches sie
versuchen ja auch in einer art
spurensuche herauszufinden warum sich
dieser bruder eigentlich das leben
genommen hat und dabei studieren sie
auch die geschichte des selbstmords sie
untersuchen philosophische schriften
dazu und klappern verschiedene motive ab
und ein motiv auf dass man immer wieder
stößt sind politisch verfolgte die karte
oder sokrates ein anderes motiv sind die
liebestollen die verliebten frau
liebeskummer kranken werther ist ein
gutes beispiel
aber nichts davon trifft auf ihren
bruder zu sagen sie warum hat er sich
umgebracht
naja das warum ist wahrscheinlich und
dort war es bleibt natürlich diese
tatsache dass er sich umgebracht hat und
ich glaube eines der großen probleme im
nachhinein es selbstmord es ist genau
diese frage
diese und antwort barkeit dieser fragen
und dass man sich nicht mehr lösen
können aus diesem warum und man bezieht
sie sind natürlich sehr stark auf sich
selbst man fragt sich immer war das ein
vorwurf oder hat man etwas verpasst da
hat man irgendeine schuld auf sich
geladen
das heißt es wird zu einer nachricht in
dieser selbstmord die man eigentlich
nicht entschlüsseln kann und ich glaube
diese und schlüssel wahrheit ist das was
einen nicht mehr loslässt und
gleichzeitig ist es ja eine eine sehr
starke zurückweisung auch die man die
man erfährt dan
was immer man habe diesen menschen es
hat einfach nicht gereicht um ihn am
leben zu erhalten und und das ist
natürlich immer eine sehr große kränkung
das heißt sie waren auch getränkt ja
selbstverständlich also es ist eine
absage an jede beziehung natürlich es
ist ein trainer der der verbindungen die
nun hat es ist der wahrscheinlich der
aus ob sie aus der akte und sich
überhaupt vorstellen könne niemand nimmt
sich aus auggen beziehungen raus und
verabschiedet sich ins nirgendwo
das ist natürlich immer eine sehr große
zurück weil sowohl eine verletzung sie
sagen asozial das stimmt so was mich
hier nicht um vorwurf ja ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich das jetzt so moralisch
sehen würde aber es ist natürlich die an
die preisgabe jeder verbindung mit den
mitmenschen und northern ireland heißt
es kein mensch ist eine insel und der
entschluss sich das leben zu nehmen
na ja und natürlich den anspruch dass
man für sich selbst etwas entscheiden
können dass man herr seiner daten ist
und frei in dem was man was man tun will
und das negiert natürlich die soziale
verantwortung die soziale einbettung
menschen sind zuallererst auch soziale
wesen
jetzt haben wir noch mal auf die zaun
zurückblicken die sie am anfang erwähnt
haben
man weiß ja auch dass jede zweite person
jemanden kennt der sich umbringen wird
oder der sich bereits umgebracht hat
also eben sehr verbreitet die todesart
wie sie schon gesagt haben deswegen
sprechen ihr denn so wenig darüber und
weswegen weisen die auch in
todesanzeigen nicht aus das zieht die
todesursache war ja das ist der ziemlich
rätselhaft
wenn man darüber sprechen muss über die
gründe und wenn man die gründe
sie erläutern will wenn man selber in
der situation ist versteht man das
vollkommen und weiß einfach nicht
worüber man sprechen will also
selbstmord entzieht sich irgend einer
normalen diskussion darüber will man
über das leben des selbstmörders reden
oder über die tat reden und ist die tat
irgend ein spiegel für sein leben das
heißt man kommt in einen bereich wo der
selbstmord sich ein selbst eine
bedeutung verschafft
die eigentlich unangemessen ist weil es
ist eigentlich nicht legitim ein leben
anhand eines selbstmordes zu bemessen
und trotzdem leuchtet es wie ein
schwarzer sommer über diese ganzen
biografie und über diese existenz und
ich glaube da fällt man schon in einem
schweigen kommt dazu dass damit
natürlich eine eine sehr starke gewalt
erfahrung auch verbunden ist also man
muss sich vorstellen
ungefähr die hälfte dieser ein
selbstmörder bringen sich auf ja sehr
grausame methoden oder erschiessen
erhängen und sich zu tode stürzen sind
die beliebtesten methoden und das hat ja
auch zur folge dass jemand diese
menschen auf findet und das heißt man
wird dieser gewahrt auch vorsichtig und
das arzt zu einer hat eine große
traumatisierung zufolge und findet man
sehr selten wurde
es ist auch so dass man zu einer
bruderschaft gehört plötzlich das merkt
man also man stößt plötzlich in einen
bereich vor wo man merkt man ist zwar
nicht alleine aber dieser bruderschaft
dahinter blieben oder angehörigen gelten
gewisse regeln und ich glaube eine
dieser regeln ist dass man einander auch
nicht zu nahe tritt darin dass man
darauf wartet dass der andere etwas dazu
sagt das dann sehr häufig nicht
geschehen was man zum beispiel nicht
fragt wenig die suizid geschehen zumal
in der region
sie sprechen ja sehr bewusst auch von
selbstmord obwohl dieses wort eigentlich
verpönt diesmal spricht heute von suizid
oder von selbsttötung warum beharren sie
darauf selbstmord zu sagen ich habe
keine bessere alternative gefunden
suizid ist natürlich ein euphemismus
durch das fremdwort unseres fremdwort
verstehen
freitod wird häufig auch gesagt ich das
wäre dann wahrscheinlich die die
positive der chor notierung aber ich
habe nichts mehr frei ist darin gefunden
oder ich fand diese in anspruch noch mit
der freiheit eine heroisierung dieser
tag die selbsttötung wäre möglich
gewesen
ich fand es einfach nicht so nicht so
schön ich finde das wort du musst auch
einen gewissen klang haben das klingt
jetzt vielleicht zu wenig und ich habe
kein besseres wort gefunden und ich
glaube auch nicht obwohl ich natürlich
weiß und ich habe dann auch ziemlich
viele reaktionen darauf gekommen warum
ich diesen dieses wort benutzt
ich glaube nicht dass ich das problem
oder die tragik dieser tat in der
diskussion über das wort das uns darüber
findet endlich erschöpfend betrachten
lässt
das habe dass wir ein nebenjob ist der
nebenschauplatz besteht darin dass man
sagt es gibt im strafrecht die
unterscheidung zwischen mord und
totschlag und der markt zeichnet sich
aus durch sogenannte niedere motive und
man möchte ein selbstmörder nicht
unterstellen dass er niedere motive
hatte wobei man natürlich sagen könnte
na ja es gibt die geschichte des
selbstmords die auch eine sehr starke
moralische dimension hat sie wo man
durchaus sagt das ist ein niederes motiv
sich selbst das leben zu nehmen das
leben wegzuschmeißen
ein akt eigentlich der unmoral aber das
wird ja nicht die schule die sie
interessiert nein obwohl man sich
manchmal wünschen würde dieser
selbstmord diese selbsttötung wäre noch
ein akt des widerstandes oder wäre eine
opposition gegen irgendeine ordnung
gegen eine göttliche ordnung meine
zulegen
wir leben in einer postheroischen zeit
wir haben kein begriff mehr selbstmord
in heroischen gesellschaften ist auch
eine möglichkeit seine ehre
wiederherzustellen oder wenn er den weg
zu gehen dass man keine chance auf sicht
liegt das ist für uns auch nicht der
fall
das heißt es bleibt eigentlich nur noch
das pragmatische dieses bilanzierende
roboter natürlich der selbstmord aus
aus einer psychischen erkrankung heraus
aber wie lahm zu ziehen kommt eigentlich
das rechnen hinzu
man versucht eine buchhaltung seines
lebens zu erstellen und schaut was
spricht dafür was spricht dagegen und
ein akt des widerstandes oder ein akt
der des unmoralischen gibt es eigentlich
darin nicht mehr liegt wahrscheinlich
auch daran dass wir keine vorstellung
mehr davon haben des lebens aus
vorbereitung auf das jenseits das leben
für uns muss sich selbst genügen wir
müssen uns selbst jeden tag dafür
rechtfertigen dass wir überhaupt noch am
leben sind das leben ist nicht mehr eine
eine hinwendung auf das jenseits dass
uns dann eben dann alle ja in aussicht
gestellt werden tönt direkt fertigen
dass wir überhaupt noch am leben sind
die interessiert mich sie schreiben
nämlich in ihrem buch es gibt diese idee
in der presse zb dass man nicht über
suizide berichten sollte weil ich die
gefahr der ansteckung gibt und man weiß
das ja auch aus der geschichte es geht
den sogenannten werther effekt dass sich
im zuge des romans von goethe plötzlich
ganz viele menschen umgebracht haben
nachdem sie werter gelesen haben also
diese tat nachgeahmt haben und in ihrem
buch sagen die dann naja was heißt
eigentlich ansteckung bei suizid das
kann ja eigentlich nur heißen dass die
argumente dafür so gut sind
glauben sie das wirklich sind die
argumente fehlen selbst war einfach sehr
sehr gut
also muss ich sagen dass das natürlich
eine politische haltung ist dieses buch
vertritt und die politische position ist
natürlich auch etwas anderes was jetzt
die position des privatmanns per fuß da
muss man gut 830 gemacht haben was das
buch stark von ihrer biografie auch
ausdrucken trotzdem ist natürlich ein
kunstwerk das heißt es gibt dort dann
auch rhetorische position habe ich
möchte der fragen nicht ausweichen
ich glaube die argumente sind dann gut
wenn man sich in dieser logik begibt
dann beginnt das leben zu bemessen wenn
man sich fragt
was steht mir noch in aussicht was war
mein leben was könnte es noch sein
das heißt wenn man zu rechnen beginnt
dann kommt man plötzlich in eine dynamik
sie sehr gefährlich ist glaube ich
weil dann besteht die gefahr dass man
jeden tag einer prüfung unterzieht und
jeden moment einer prüfung unterzieht
und dann verhalten sich plötzlich heißt
sind die dienste dienstag meines lebens
wirklich so schön und die mit wochen die
donnerstage wünscht man sich nicht eine
einen großen langen urlaub vor der traum
seines lebens eigentlich und ich glaube
dieses berechnen der dieser blick auf
das leben in der in der summierung ist
etwas sehr gefährlich ist ich glaube das
leben wird zuerst gelebt werden und die
besten momente sind ja wenn wir
überhaupt vergessen dass wir überhaupt
am leben sind die momente der ekstase
der meditation des rausches auch wenn
wir uns nicht mehr gefahr werden was wir
eigentlich haben und was wir tun was wir
sind und deshalb glaube ich ist das
gefährliche daran dass wir einen blick
auf das leben werfen wie der
selbstmörder der dann eben diese rechnen
diese buch erstellt also diese diesen
zugang der buchhaltung den finden sie
keine gute sache wenn es darum geht
wirklich im leben zu stehen
es gibt auch einen interessanten moment
in der zürcher poetikvorlesung nein ich
tausche nichts verkehrt es ist in der
ich glaube der antrittsvorlesung an der
fau berlin diese gehalten haben da gehen
sie dieser wendung nach das beste kommt
noch ein satz der mir ja oft und selber
auch sagen sie sagen das ist eigentlich
kein trost das ist eine art eine
beschwichtigung dass wir nicht wahrhaben
wollen dass wir sterben
das beste kommt noch glauben sie für
sich persönlich auch das beste kommt gar
nicht mehr oder finden sie es einfach
unzulässig so was auszusprechen
ja jedenfalls glaube ich dass das leben
das individuell individuelle leben kein
happy end also am ende unseres lebens
steht eine große katastrophe
das beste kommt noch ist natürlich das
bürgerliche credo ist auch das
säkularisierte credo des christentums
das heißt das leben heraus vorstellung
als vorbereitung auf die himmlische
gnade der kapitalismus auf was
säkularisiert es braucht diese ewige
entwicklung dieses unabsehbarer
eigentlich des fortschrittes und ich
glaube da hat es einen bruch gegeben in
diesem bewusstsein wir haben nicht mehr
wirklich das gefühl dass für unsere
kinder noch etwas wesentlich besseres
oder mehr wohlstand oder mehr glück zur
verfügung stehen wird das für unsere
generation und ich glaube das hat zu
einer beinahe zu einem einbruch geführt
eigentlich in unserem blick auf uns
selbst um auf unsere gesellschaft ein
einbruch auch dieses enthusiasmus und
des optimismus
unsere eigene entwicklung gegenüber und
ich weiß nicht genau was da jetzt kommen
könnt aber diese lisa liebt es wenn man
aus ganz persönliche leben guckt dann
denke ich immer wenn man nicht glaubt
dass das beste noch kommt dann sind ja
einig möglicherweise die gründe für den
suizid schon relativ gut gleichzeitig
hat es natürlich auch wieder so etwas
bilanzieren dass das man alle momente im
leben vergleichen kann
möglicherweise kann man das ja gar nicht
also ich weiß nicht wir sehen gilt aber
meine besten momente sind tatsächlich
die momente also die angemessenen
momente die momente die nicht irgendwie
in rechnung gestellt werden auf etwas
was ich erreichen will oder wo ich nicht
etwas tue um etwas anderes dafür zu
erhalten sondern ruhig auf gehe in
diesem moment wo ich nicht daran denke
was noch kommen könnte oder was noch war
das heißt dieses aufgehen
im augenblick ist übrigens auch ein
grund für das glück beim schreiben also
wenn es darum geht dass ich wirklich in
dieser kontemplation zu geben
mit sich um dem wort das sind das sind
die großen glücksmomente und wenn man
sich fragte was muss ich in dem moment
investieren damit ich dann etwas
besseres zurückbekommen oder was kann
ich jetzt noch aus spaß
damit sich dann einen höheren peter
kabel ist unglaublich auf einem auf
einem falschen weg
also mir gefällt das licht das beste
kommt noch heißt ja das ist jetzt auch
nicht gut ist heißt das sich in einer um
zufriedenheit leben muss und dieser
unzufriedenheit mit der kann ich mich
nicht abfinden
sprechen wir über thun lukas bärfuss ist
es buch spielt zum teilen tun oder es
beginnt in thun und wir schauen uns mal
zusammen bild und ton hier ein schönes
bild ist ja eigentlich ein hübsches
städtchen sie aber fahren in ihrem roman
tun ist ein kauf ist glaube ich primär
an kasernenareal bei ihnen sie sagen
auch dass die also dass die der
ich-erzähler muss seinen wortschatz
reduzieren wenn er nach thun kommt dann
muss alles was ein bisschen niveau hat
runter drosseln damit die leute
verstehen was man tun sie gar nichts zu
tun
ich finde es ja vollkommen recht es ist
eine wunderschöne stadt mit tollen
menschen in einer wundervollen gegen
thun ausnahme kommt ja auch nicht vor es
ist die stadt in der kleist einige zeit
verbracht hat eine stadt an einem see in
einen fluss der begriff des kaufes
betrifft glaube ich jede gegend dieser
welt also wenn man das den fokus ein
bisschen schärfer stellt dann entpuppt
sich eigentlich jeder gegen das provinz
glaube nicht ich glaube die mechanismen
die in diesem buch beschrieben werden
betreffen überhaupt nicht sehen will
jetzt nur dieser stadt am fuße der
raupen sondern sind dinge die überall
gefunden werden können
es gibt natürlich aber schon einen
unterschied zwischen 2014 und den 70er
80er jahre
ausdehnen oder da ich diese stadt
bekommt habe ich bin sehr früh weg ende
der achtziger jahre und das war
natürlich schon eine andere geht weil es
einfach eine andere zeit war da die
armee noch die wesentliche rolle
gespielt in dieser staub der glaube ist
die munitionsfabrik und die
konstruktions werkstätten und eigentlich
nicht viel mehr
und da hat sich thun glaube ich schon
sehr viele ins offenere entwickelt und
ich habe diese enge sehr sehr stark
empfunden das muss ich schon sagen
obwohl das natürlich auch viel mit mir
zu tun hat also mit meiner mit meiner
geschichte in dieser stadt und ich
wollte da eigentlich immer weg rico beim
wer hat ihnen in der weltwoche dunkel
vorgeworfen weil natürlich solche
aussagen wie dass man den wortschatz
reduzieren muss wenn man eine stadt
betritt die zumindest so beschrieben ist
das wäre es tun dann ist es
wahrscheinlich schwierig anzuerkennen
der städter der auf die kleinstadt guckt
sie sind irgendwie märz umstädter
geworden können sie diesen vorwurf
nachvollziehen muss ich ja dunkel das
ist ja nicht besonders freundlich oder
finden sie das in ordnung man darf sich
diesen denken dann auch zu legen
nein aber das ist jetzt wirklich keine
kein vorwurf der mich betrifft oder
zudem nicht stellung nehmen möchte man
kann dieses buch natürlich so lesen
das ist ihm unbenommen ich glaube aber
nicht dass es ein buch eines städters
über die ihr über die provinz ist und
von diesen eindruck haben könnten dieser
eindruck ja auch aufgenommen es gibt
auch solche aus passagen in diesem buch
war genau diese position sehr
selbstkritisch diskutiert werden und
wenn es so etwas gibt wie eine
überheblichkeit
dann ist auch dass seine eine politische
haltung gläubig und die hat vielleicht
mehr eine rolle das spiel zwischen
dieser bruder beziehung was jetzt von
der stadt zur provinz ich meine ich lebe
in zürich und zürich ist mindestens so
ein café tun
das lassen wir mal so stehen
sprechen wir über das quartier oder den
crawler sie haben ja im vorfeld das
gespräch gesagt der quali ist kein bär
und wo man mama sagt qual aber es ist
ein beuteltier ein deutscher zeuge hat
nichts zu tun mit der familie der bären
dennoch manchmal spricht man von qual
aber darüber sprechen wir nicht nur noch
vom quartier das hat ihrem buch den
titel gegeben und jetzt müssen wir den
bogen schlagen
wie kommen sie vom selbstmord ihres
bruders zum tier des cva der einfachste
grund ist dass dieser punkte den
pfadfindern abend trug war und dass es
übereinstimmungen gab zwischen ihm und
den eigenschaften die man diesem tier zu
schreibt die frappierend sind und dass
ich mich gefragt habe woher kommt dieser
einstimmung haben diese kinder dieser
jugendlichen die ihm damals was als kind
den namen gegeben haben etwas gewusst
von diesem wesen vom wesen des punktes
vom wesen des programms hat er diesen
wesen nachgelebt das heißt wurde es im
zur richtschnur eigentlich für sein
eigenes leben
was war zuerst ist zuerst der name und
dann ist das leben das diesen namen
entspricht oder war es umgekehrt
was sind überhaupt die eigenschaften
dieses tieres was zeichnet dieses tier
aus es wurde zu einer spurensuche auch
zu einer möglichkeit einer eine
orientierung in dieser
orientierungslosigkeit die frage des
toten das ist natürlich sehr wesentlich
also
man stellt ja fest eines tages dass man
so aussieht wie man heißt ich sehe aus
wie ein lukas ist man kann sich fast
nichts mehr anderes vorstellen von den
anderen menschen man ähnelt wird sich
diesen namen oder gibt diesen namen auch
ein gesicht
und das sind ja vor aufklärerischen
ideen eigentlich und glaubt ja nicht
daran dass irgendeine
schicksalhaftigkeit mit einem namen
verbunden ist und dieses ihrer optionen
spiegelt natürlich auch das irrationale
im umgang mit dem selbst nun an sich
interessant ist da diese namensgebungen
sie sprechen da etwas anders mich immer
auch beschäftigt wenn man in touristen
ordnen ist dann sieht man noch immer so
tasten die ru stehen oder karten mit
vornamen drauf und dann eine
beschreibung was diese person die diesen
namen trägt auszeichnet und ein bisschen
ist natürlich wie bei den horoskopen die
texte sind immer so aufgefasst dass sie
eigentlich auf jede person zu treffen
dennoch haben ein bisschen den eindruck
stimmt schon gewisse namen stehen auch
für gewisse personen und die ähneln sich
irgendwie ja das ist sicher so ich mein
haben es ist kein detlef und eine so
sagen es keine kredite und wir haben
natürlich bild das an diesen namen und
und das geht natürlich darauf rückt
projektionen auf die menschen die diesen
namen tragen
in meinem fall gibt es diese
übereinstimmung am rande bemerkt was ich
seit immer eine große schwäche gehabt
habe für die gegend südlich von neapel
weil dort die fotografischen philosophen
gelebt haben paar meter zum beispiel und
lukas ist tatsächlich der ausflug an ihm
stammt aus dieser gegend stammen als ich
das erste mal
elia war dieser diesem zentrum der
antiken philosophie und fühlte ich mich
auch auf eine gewisse weise zu hause man
kann sich fragen
das nur eine projektion oder gibt es da
eine übereinstimmen das ist nicht so
entscheidend glaube ich und das nicht
entschuldbar ist natürlich etwas eher
literarisches ja was sehr viele
möglichkeiten offen lässt der
interpretation des assoziativen des
traumes natürlich auch und der der reise
im kopf uns diese freunde ihres bruders
gaben nun also diesen namen qual login
pfadfinder namen und sie schreiben dann
eigentlich eine art kultur und
naturgeschichte dieses quartiere und
eben auch der eroberung von australien
jetzt seien über dieses tier sprechen
sie sagen kann das ist ein tier das hat
das existenz prinzip ohne ehrgeiz zu
sein
auf meinen sie damit es gibt eine sehr
schöne schilderungen eines green koala
forschers der 456 tage lang ein exemplar
beobachtete um zwei mann ist etwas
passiert was in diesen anderthalb jahren
gab es zwei ereignisse einmal abteilung
gewechselt
besondere markup seine begegnung mit
einem konfrontiert das heißt dieses tier
tut wirklich buchstäblich nichts dass
schläft über 20 stunden am tag und hat
seinen organismus sein metabolismus auf
das absolute minimum reduziert es
ernährt sich von einer neuerung die
eigentlich giftig ist die kaum
nährstoffe besitzt
es muss der eine eigene verdauungs an
einen verdauungsapparat entwickeln damit
es überhaupt das vertrauen kann diese
nahrung
es lebt eine existenz dass unsere
existenz prinzip so ziemlich allen
widerspricht und war sehr erfolgreich
evolutionäre also unglaublich da muss
man sagen absolut es gibt seit 20
millionen jahren also die ersten
fossilien sind zu haben
es ist eine möglichkeit der existenz die
durchaus seine vorteile hat natürlich es
gibt kaum aggression und
sie haben eine eine eine hinwendung zu
ihrer umwelt die unvergleichlich ist
also es sind eigentlich produkte ihrer
umwelt so wie wir es niemals sein können
wir haben kein natürliches habitat der
mensch wir müssen immer gestalten
wir sind nirgends zu hause denn zwar
alles nach unseren kriterien zu
beeinflussen koalas nicht die sind dort
wo sie sehen und die fressen was ihnen
buchstäblich vor die nase hält
aber eigentlich ist ja auch interessant
sie sagen jetzt dieser koloss ist
quartier das lebt ohne ehrgeiz
eigentlich gibt es ja auch diese momente
in denen sie schreiben das hat eben auch
seine berechtigung seine schönheit weil
es einfach nichts tun weil es sich
komplett entspannt oder man hat
zumindest den eindruck es ist ein sehr
faules teams schläft sehr viel und das
ist eine provokation in unserer welt in
der wir eigentlich in so einer hetzjagd
in so einer treibjagd leben
ich weiß gar nicht nur ob das nur für
unsere welt tatsächlich der fall ist ich
will das gar nicht aus dem post
kapitalismus der beschränken bereits die
aborigines fanden sich sehr provoziert
von diesem tier und mussten es in eine
mythologie einbetten in der ersten platz
eines mittäters bekam und eines listigen
kerlchen etwas wasser spielt zum
beispiel und auf eine ganz seltsame
weise mit der kreation der welt
verbunden ist es trinkt auch nicht was
in den leuten ja natürlich und das ist
natürlich eine für menschen die kaum
zwei tage ohne wasser sein können noch
zusätzlich eine provokation
sie mussten es auch mit einem gewissen
top belegen
das heißt sie durften oder gewisse
stemmen durften corners nur mit dem fell
braten das heißt sie dürften es nicht
heute was möglicherweise damit zu tun
hat
das ist eine gewisse kontrolle des des
tötungs triebes brauchte weg was sind
die perfekte bäume oder die rennen nicht
weg die wehren sich nicht
die kann man wirklich vom baum holen und
töten und essen was auch zu einer großen
reduktion des bestandes geführt hat
bereits und sie haben eigentlich nicht
einmal den ehrgeiz am leben zu bleiben
wenn sie so weit gehen ja ich glaube sie
haben einfach nicht damit gerechnet dass
irgendjemand nach ihrem leben trachten
könnten es gab kaum find es gab einige
dinge groß aber die waren keine gefahr
weil sich nicht leisten können und so
waren sie auf jedem baum sind haben sie
nichts zu befürchten
erstaunlicherweise ist war es zweimal
eine verwandlung die das bedurfte eine
eine metaphorische verwandlung dieses
tieres das überhaupt das überleben
gesichert hat bei den mavericks war es
die verwandlung war zu diesem toten tier
zu dieser kreatur die mit dem wasser und
mit dem master zugang essentiell
verbunden ist und er in australien nach
diesem großen ausrottung wellen zwischen
1860 und 1920 gab es eine besinnung auf
die nation auf das eigenständige auf das
was es nur dort gibt und qual das gibt
es nur in australien und ein kinderbuch
war es dann tatsächlich dass die
empathie der menschen für dieses tier
geweckt habe damals mit mannes beinahe
ausgerottet haben und in diesem
kinderbuch erscheint es als
weltreisender als gewiss das kerlchen
das immer essen will und forscht ist und
viele streichen kopf hat und alles dinge
die total den koala widersprechen als
erreichen ist furchtbar für carlitos
fressen können
es hat sieht sich ja gedauert bis man
ein koala exportieren kommt und der das
überlebt
verfressen sind sie nicht sie kommen mit
äußerst wenig nahrung aus und einen
streich hat wahrscheinlich noch kein
körper gespielt
das muster ist vielleicht auch
verwandeln um diesen tier herr zu werden
weil es einfach dermaßen nicht in unsere
denke kauft jetzt wer mir noch
vielleicht auf dieses lebensprinzip ohne
ehrgeiz noch mehr eingehen das ist eine
provokation mal in unserem leben sie
sagen jetzt das war früher auch schon so
da ist in anderen kulturen auch so aber
es ja schon so in unserem leben spielt
ehrgeiz oder das getriebensein eine
große rolle
sprechen wir über den ehrgeiz ich habe
den eindruck in unserer sogenannten
leistungsgesellschaft in unserer welt
hat ehrgeiz im moment ganz schlechte
karten
warum eigentlich weil man könnte auch
sagen er hat auch sehr viel zu tun mit
leidenschaft ja das wäre das andere wort
aber sie haben freunde auch ein ressort
der welt und das ist die faulheit und
dort ist natürlich die moralische
kommunikation bereits enthalten
lang foul das heißt man geht in ein
stadion über der der auflösung der
identität das bedeutet verfaulen heißt
übergehen seine umwelt das verlieren der
der eigenen konturen und ich glaube
diese dieser blick auf die existenz als
auf abgrenzung das heißt dass wir uns
von den anderen abschotten und uns
differenzieren vor den ahnen das ist
glaube ich das charakteristische die
provokation des faulen des nicht
ehrgeizigen ist nicht so sehr dass er
nichts zum sonnen ist die zurückweisung
des anspruchs der anderen oder wer faul
ist das thema etwas zurück baracke die
diese große figur von herman melville
sagt immer dass er etwas lieber nicht
tun möchte was immer man iman trägt eine
pflicht die weist er zurück und bringt
dadurch das ganze system liegt an der
bürokratie natürlich ins wanken
ich glaube auch dass robinson crusoe
beispielsweise oder der letzte mensch
die können nicht frau die sein
weil faulheit ist angewiesen darauf dass
es so etwas gibt es eine gesellschaft
und mir fällt dazu auch ein dass es bis
vor nicht so langer zeit ich glaube
sogar immer noch heute so genannte
arbeitserziehungsanstalt gibt in der
schweiz das heißt junge menschen vor
allem männer die arbeitsscheue jesus
waren wurden dahin gebracht damit sie
lernten wie man arbeitet und arbeit ist
verbunden natürlich mit dem ehrgeiz ist
verbunden damit dass man nicht zufrieden
ist mit der welt wie man sich jetzt
befindet mit der situation in
sicherheitstor findet und dass man sie
in seinem sinne verändert und dieser
veränderungswille bedingt natürlich auch
eine eine zerstörung eine zerstörung des
bisherigen eine eine entwicklung ist
immer damit verbunden das etwas was war
zu grunde gehen muss abgelöst werden
musste ich etwas was dann kommen wird
und da ist glaube ich eine ich will
nicht sagen eine einer essen
der aps etwas in der gesellen der
menschlichen entwicklung enthalten dass
das wir nicht dass wir nicht herauslösen
können unsere zivilisation ist bedingt
durch diesen ewigen wandel und durch
dieses ewige zerstören das bekommt und
den ersatz durch etwas neu und man kann
sich aber auch positiv werte man muss es
ja nicht nur aus was in einer zerstörung
aufzeigen sondern kultur ist im
wesentlichen ehrgeiz im sinne von
leistung im sinne von weiterentwicklung
aber ich glaube wenn sie jetzt diese
ganzen kapitalismus kritiken auch
erwähnt haben
da geht es ja auch immer darum dass man
sich fragt ist da nicht der ehrgeiz mein
ehrgeiz ist es meine leidenschaft oder
ist es mir auf getroffen wird es mir
sozusagen bevor also wahrscheinlich ist
das problematische element er die
fremdbestimmung ja sozusagen ob man
etwas tun will ist da ist sehr sehr
schwierig also ich stehe in der küche
und ich frage mich ob ich ab waschen
will
wahrscheinlich will ich nicht abwaschen
aber ich will abgewaschen haben ist
ich will dass das geschehen nämlich weg
ist die momente wo man etwas will aus
sich selbst hinaus das sind die wirklich
revolutionären momente im leben und sie
spürt man dann auch und weiß auch und
jetzt ziemlich viel gegenwind ehrenden
also das sind dann auch die die großen
autonomen momente aber ich glaube in der
regel ist da ist der wille natürlich
frauen ein wille weil man die
konsequenzen fürchtet und dass man etwas
tut weil man nicht will dass etwas
anderes eintritt was sie gesagt haben
über das positive bei der entwicklung
ich glaube das ist ja die die sich der
aufklärung natürlich auch die
bürgerliche sicht auf unsere geschichte
das heißt dass wir uns immer
weiterentwickeln zu einer besseren
gesellschaft zu einem besseren menschen
ich glaube die kunst gar nicht trauen in
der kunst gibt es diese entwicklung
nicht
es ist nicht so dass irgendein
kunstwerken schriftsteller einen
früheren schriftsteller überflüssig
gemacht hätte oder widerlegt hätte das
ist der die entwicklung der technologie
es ist nicht so dass man sagen kann nur
eines james joyce gegeben hat brauchen
wir shakespeare licht und shakespeare
hätte irgendetwas an software class
überflüssig gemacht gemacht so ist es
nicht die bedingungen der existenz sie
gleich geblieben wobei man sie auch
vielleicht nicht einmal bewerten muss im
sinne von es wird moralisch besser mit
unserer welt ich meine diese idee gab es
natürlich in der aufklärung gewählt wird
besser moralisch gesehen besser
vielleicht kann man auch einfach
festhalten
wir sind gestaltende wir menschen machen
die welt weiter wir erfinden sie weiter
und jeder in seinem eigenen leben also
wenn ich vom leidenschaft gesprochen
habe da habe ich den eindruck da steckt
doch auch bei ihnen ganz stark der
künstler drin dieses fast schon nicht
spanische leben gefährlich sei die noch
mit mach etwas aus deinem leben da kommt
die leidenschaft hervor und das ist doch
auch eine form von ehrgeiz
ja das ist sicher so wobei das bild das
sie da gezeigt haben dass wir gestalten
gesehen und dass wir etwas weiter
entwickeln das stimmt natürlich nur sehr
beschränkt denn alles was wir
verbrauchen die ressourcen die wir
verbrauchen
die werden den kommenden generationen
nicht mehr zur verfügung stehen der
rumänische ökonomen george s rück noch
das sehr radikal formuliert hat gesagt
ein leben in der gegenwart bedeutet ein
leben weniger in der zukunft einfach die
ressourcen nicht mehr da sind und die
physikalischen gesetze gelten leider
auch für die wirtschaft so etwas wie ein
kreislauf geht gibt es nicht es gibt nur
ein eigentlich eine ewige bewegung auf
den kältetod des universums zu und ich
glaube das wird uns langsam jetzt
bewusst wird uns bewusst auch beim öl
das zur neige geht beispielsweise es
wird uns bewusst
bei den großen globalen probleme die auf
uns zukommen wie der klimaerwärmung zum
beispiel dass der lebensstandard den wir
heute haben in der zukunft
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zu
rechtfertigen sei und das hat schon zu
einem knick geführt in diesen vorwärts
streben und diesen leidenschaftlich wir
müssen halt nochmal machen sondern wir
unterwegs sind ist es gut
jetzt spricht der moralist lukas bärfuss
und die nz hat sie einmal als
moralisches gewissen des
schauspielhauses zürich bezeichnet sie
sind ja dramaturg am schauspielhaus
zürich sie schreiben sehr viele stücke
gefällt ihnen dieses leben das
moralische gewissen zu sein
also ich habe kein problem mit der moral
murat bedeutet für mich die frage nach
dem guten und im richtigen leben für
mich ganz persönlich auch ja ich muss
auch sagen was eigentlich sämtliche
schrift ständig bewohnte waren
moralisten
ich bewundere zb dostojewski ein großer
moralist
es gibt auch negative moralisten
natürlich ist marokko ein großer
moralist
die beschreibung der wirklichkeit wird
er häufig gleich zu einer moralischen
man beschreibt einfach was ist und wenn
man auch versucht von den widersprüchen
des eigenen lebens zu reden dann wird
man sehr schnell zum organisten wenn man
einen blick wirft auch auf die dinge die
unvereinbar sind eigentlich auch die
ambivalenzen habe auf die spannungen in
den mann gefangen ist und für mich ist
es nicht so sehr ernst die
programmierung eines lebensstils oder
irgendeiner politischen hürden überhaupt
nicht sondern im gegenteil das fragende
ist für mich eigentlich das moralische
bei ihm da werden sie ja schon sehr
politisch sie haben zum beispiel damals
als es um die verschärfung des
asylgesetzes ging haben sie in der
tagespresse ein artikel platziert mit
dem titel das ist eine schande
das heißt sie haben schon angegriffen
moralischen vorwurf gemacht wann werden
sie so politisch auch polemisch
politisch also jetzt in diesem in diesem
fall bei diesem artikel war es
eigentlich gelang der anständigkeit
glaube ich dass ich fahre einfach nicht
an stellen sich von leuten die das große
geografische glück hatten in der schweiz
geboren zu werden
menschen die das nicht taten dieses
glück auf diese weise zu drangsalieren
also ich glaube wenn man ihn noch mehr
wegnimmt vom wenigen dass man die
überhaupt zu spricht wenn man sie dazu
zwingt in luftschutzbunkern zu leben
hatte ich das einfach für unanständig
und das hat war etwas sehr instinkt
haften muss ich sagen das war auch nicht
sehr durchdacht oder da gibt es kein
programm dahinter ich fand das ganz
unmittelbar einfach nicht in ordnung das
war lukas bärfuss der quasi einen
leserbrief fast schon schreiben wollte
aber natürlich klar schriftsteller haben
sie dann die möglichkeit einen seite
also bei mir ist das ist natürlich eine
biografie ich weiß was es bedeutet wenn
man
nichts hat und wenn man auf der straße
lebt und wenn man marginalisiert ist und
wenn man keine möglichkeiten hat und
wenn man ausgeschlossen wird von der
teilhabe an allem an der bildung und ich
glaube dieses wenn sie auch das auf das
asylrecht zu sprechen kommen die
menschen die ihnen dieses land kommen
das ist einfach nur dass anträge sich
dieser globalisierung ein
die schweizerische wirtschaft macht gute
geschäfte in gegenden wo er dann diese
menschen kommen und ich glaube die idee
dass es noch so etwas gibt wie die
grenzen das gilt eigentlich nur noch für
diese menschen das kapital hat längst
keine grenzen mehr
die wirtschaft hat keine grenzen alles
wird globalisiert und jene die diese
grenzen noch am meisten zu spüren
gekommen sind sind die ärmsten und ich
glaube auch dass es legitim ist war für
sich selbst eine bessere zukunft zu
verlangen egal aus welcher welt reden
und sie haben sich selber gesprochen sie
haben gesagt sie wissen was es heisst
marginalisiert zu werden
was meinen sie genau ja also ich habe
einfach einen einen wesentlichen teil
meiner jugend auf der straße verbracht
und war nirgends zu hause und habe
versucht nicht von tag zu tag
durchzuschlagen und kennen die
gesellschafter durchaus auch von der von
der unteren seite und bin da natürlich
vielleicht auch biografisches etwas
empfindlicher als andere menschen weil
ich einfach weiß was das heißt kein geld
zu haben und am rande dieser
gesellschaft zuletzt eigentlich wahnsinn
wenn man dies weiß was jetzt gerade
erzählt haben wenn man ihre biografie
studiert und dann sieht was sie für
einweg hingelegt haben
sie waren vor zehn jahren haben sie
angefangen mit theater mit der
theatergruppe 400asa haben sie begonnen
dramaturg zu arbeiten sie haben stücke
geschrieben mittlerweile sind sie
hausautor am zürcher schauspielhaus sie
haben ganz ganz viele preise schon
erhalten am ersten juni hatten sie den
solothurner literaturpreis
sie sind ein viel gefeiert hat dramatik
im gesamten deutschsprachigen raum zwei
romane geschrieben
wie kam es zu diesem weg lukas bärfuss
sie haben wahrscheinlich der ehrgeiz
kein nein das bin ich sicher nicht also
ich hab mich schon eine gewisse
existenzielle unruhe auch eine große
leidenschaft
ich habe irgendwann mal das lesen
entdeckt das war auf der einen seite der
grund ja meine randständigkeit also ich
habe erlebt dass lesen auch gefährlich
ist weil man natürlich ein westen erhält
aus einem dann nicht mehr so warm
postens viel gemacht aber es gibt auch
gedanklich stoppte und madame bovary
vergleichen aber dort wird auch diese
gefahr des lesens und selektive welt
beschrieben wird das habe ich auch
erlebt das hat mich um tauglich gemacht
für die schule zum beispiel dass ich so
ein nordischer leser war in der jugend
und dann war's aber gleichzeitig
natürlich meine rettung weil ist ein weg
gefunden habe
daraus zu schreiben sie schreibe weil
ich wenn ich immer gelesen habe und ich
glaube auch dass man sagt ja häufig das
zerschneiden einen isoliert es ist
einsam macht und ich habe eigentlich das
gegenteil erlebt ich habe das schreiben
sehr stark in die gesellschaft und zu
den leuten gebracht und dann war es
einfach eine inanspruchnahme einer
gewissen runde in dieser gesellschaft
sich heute schriftsteller sein und ich
wollte schreiben dann ein leben
bestreiten und und ich habe immer
menschen getroffen die das akzeptiert
haben und die die mich so gesehen haben
wie ich das gerne wollte und das hat
nichts zu tun mit leistung überhaupt
nicht oder nicht zu tun mit ehrgeizigen
ist eigentlich eine gnade ich kaum das
was ich bin nur seien dadurch das
einverständnis der online und ich habe
immer menschen getroffen die mich darin
und
jetzt haben sie sich für das
interessiert haben muss ich geschrieben
habe
deshalb ist der ehrgeiz natürlich nur
ein kleiner teil
wir müssen darauf hoffen dass die
abenden und so nehmen wie er sein aber
ein stück weit wenn ihr noch einmal auf
die mehr moralische linie zurückgehen
geht es ja schon auch immer darum
verantwortung zu übernehmen für sein
leben das zumindest glaube ich nicht man
auch in diesem buch kva und man dies in
ganz vielen von ihrem stück können sie
haben vorhin ihre auseinandersetzung mit
dem eher dünn
im stück öl haben sie erwähnt ich habe
mit großem gewinn ihr theaterstück
malaga gelesen muss auch ganz spezifisch
um verantwortung geht da geht es um die
verantwortung eines eines ehepaars wir
sehen ein bild aus malaga hier ein
ehepaar das die streitet die beiden
waisen einander ständig gegenseitig die
verantwortung zu keiner will eigentlich
seine karriere pläne begraben keiner
will zuständig sein für die gemeinsame
tochter die sie haben beide möchten
gerne das wochenende zu verbringen wie
sie sich ausgedacht haben um
schlussendlich endet das ganze in einem
desaster weil die tochter nämlich
verunglückt und zwar sehr schwer
verunglückt
was heißt dass verantwortung zu
übernehmen in einem leben wie viel
verantwortung muss den sein
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das
qualifiziert
ich glaube nur dass man sie augenblicke
sehr stark spürt wo man die
verantwortung delegiert oder wenn man
wegschaut
ich empfinde das immer gehört nicht
jeden tag eigentlich war ich merke wie
gesagt sich jetzt etwas tun oder hier
wäre jetzt etwas gefordert von mir
selbst jetzt hier bin ich und hier
geschieht etwas
warum bringen ich mich nicht ins spiel
und häufig bringt man sich nicht ins
spiel aus gründen der scham oder des
schlechten gewissens der faulheit
meinetwegen weil man beim an weg sieht
ich hatte vor noch gar nicht so lange
zeit dein erlebnis bei 3
littering problem und ich habe immer
darauf gewartet dass irgend jemand kommt
und diesen abfall weg räumen weil es
muss doch jemand gegenteil die
verantwortung für die sauberkeit liches
paris und chicago und es war frühmorgens
ich war dort in einem park und da war
ein jogger und der hat gesehen dass
irgendwo eine coladose rummler und der
heißt zu dieser coladose genommen und
hat sich geworfen
und da habe ich plötzlich begriffen dass
ich vielleicht nicht auf die beste
möglichkeit warten sollte nämlich dass
irgendjemand kommt mir die arbeit
wegnimmt oder abnehmen sondern was ich
vielleicht die zweit- oder drittbeste
möglichkeit nehmen sollte und den müll
selber weg räumen muss und ich glaube
diese angst vor diesen vor diesen
kontakt auch weil das hat immer etwas zu
tun mit mit beschmutzung auch und mit
berührung mit dem mit dem fremden und
mit dem was man nicht versteht und
gerade in unserer gesellschaft ist der
reichtum natürlich auch immer ein mittel
der isolierung der erfahrungs vermeidung
unser wohlstand bringt uns dazu dass wir
mit gewissen dingen nicht mehr in
berührung kommen müssen und nicht mehr
in berührung kommen wollen
ich glaube aber dass dort den worten
eine große lebendigkeit lege ich stelle
für mich fest wenn ich mich einlasse auf
die durchaus schwierigen dinge auch was
sich dann intensiver leben nicht
unbedingt unberührter und und anbieter
aber aber näher am puls und näher am
arten der dinge also für mich ist
verantwortung nicht unbedingt nur eine
leistungen auch eine möglichkeit
denn den leben nahezu können
mag sein aber dennoch ist es ja in
vielerlei hinsicht kann es zumindest
auch eine last sein oder verantwortung
zu übernehmen heißt auch gewisse dinge
zu tun die man vielleicht nicht tun
möchte aber als ich von gefragt habe wie
viel verantwortung wir vielleicht auch
nicht so sehr wie viel an quantität
sondern mehr auch die frage
verantwortung hat er immer damit auch zu
tun worauf ja nicht unseren blick
richten
bild gesagt darf man einfach die
verantwortung
übernehmen sie die eigene katze das
war's oder muss man sich verantwortlich
fühlen für die gesamte welt für die
schicksale in anderen ländern zu weit
nein muss man sich natürlich nicht ich
kann es einfach nicht ausblenden
countryman jeden von niemandem verlangen
aber für sie persönlich geht es nicht
anders
also ich glaube dass diese konzentration
und diese fokussierung auf die kürze
eine unglaubliche leistung ist da muss
man wirklich viel tun um nur die eigene
katze zu sehen und mir gelingt das nicht
wenn jemand in diesem zustand kommt aus
der nur die eigene katze sieht dann habe
ich durchaus eine gewisse bewunderung
dafür
ich lebe in einer welt die vielfach
verbunden ist mit meinem alltag ich muss
nicht mal die zeitung lesen sondern ich
muss nur fragen stellen woher kommen die
dinge die ich an meinem körper tragen
was sind das für für lebensmittel die
ich esse woher kommt der strom aus
meiner steckdose und wie kommt das gas
in dieser turbinen die den strom
produzieren wie kommt das umrühren in
die atomkraft das heißt allein meine
neugier das ist moralisch vollkommen
unterschiedlich allein meine neugier
bringt mich natürlich dazu dass ich
entdecke dass das mein eigenes leben
alles mit dem leben alle auf dieser welt
verbunden ist haben sie vorhin gesagt es
ist eine ungemeine leistung sich nur
verantwortlich zu finden für die katz
der bruder in diesem buch da fühlt sich
nur verantwortlich für die eigene
handtasche auf dem dachboden habt ihr
denn dieser bruder jetzt in ganz
persönlich auch etwas voraus in dieser
fähigkeit auszublenden ja voraus würde
ja irgendwie schon wieder diese
entwicklung inszenieren das heißt dass
er irgendwo weiter war ganz sicher
anders und hat ganz andere methoden des
lebens gefunden und dort drinnen gibt es
dinge die ich ja durchaus bewundere
vielleicht auch eine
eine andere genussfähigkeit als jetzt
meine genussfähigkeit oder eine eine
andere ruhe auch dem leben gegenüber
weil das problem ist natürlich dass der
suizid eigentlich das zurück weiß dass
man glaubt er hätte diese ruhe nicht
gefunden aber so war es nicht also ich
kann den hass durch ausgelassenen
menschen und aus menschen der dem leben
gegenüber eine durchaus auch positive
haltung hatte dieses voraushaben gefällt
mir nicht ganz sicher anders und diese
andersartigkeit die gefällt mir und von
daher könnte ich wahrscheinlich auch
etwas lernen
zum schluss was mich auch beschäftigt
hat ist wirklich diese beziehung
zwischen diesen beiden brüdern in diesem
buch sie selber haben schon erwähnt sie
sind vater sie haben zwei kinder eine
tochter einen sohn
ist es für sie als vater wichtig dass
diese beiden kinder sich wenn sie mal
erwachsen sind gut verstehen
untereinander
ja also das habe ich mir noch gar nicht
überlegt weil sie verstehen sich
wunderbar manchmal überhaupt nicht
die haben konflikte sie lieben sich und
die sind in einer äußerst lebendigen
beziehung und beschäftigen sich mit
einer ich glaube das ist das wesentliche
dass sie einander nicht egal sind die
indifferenz dass das würde mich stören
aber das ist weder sie noch er danke für
dieses gespräch lukas bärfuss raum zu
vergleichen
[Musik]